[Music]
good evening at welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there was a time not so
long ago when if you wanted to commit
treason you had to work for it you'd
meet your handler in a public park in
Vienna and pass him the nuclear codes
where he'd set up a shortwave radio
transmitter in your basement and calling
troop movements to the enemy that's how
people used to betray their country the
standards are much lower now though
according to Democrats Donald Trump
committed treason merely by answering a
hypothetical question from a reporter
here's how it happened in a recent
interview George Stephanopoulos asked
the president what he might do if a
foreign government offered his campaign
damaging information about one of his
opponents here's how the president
responded your campaign this time around
if foreigners if Russia if China if
someone else offers you information on
opponents should they accept it or
should they call the FBI I think maybe
you do both I think you might want to
listen I don't there's nothing wrong
with listening if somebody called from a
country Norway we have information on
your opponent oh I think I'd want to
hear you want that kind of interference
in our elections it's not an
interference they have information I
think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong I'd go maybe to the FBI
if I thought there was something wrong
so here's the scenario
Norway calls and tells you something
embarrassing about bata well Roarke
maybe he wears a wig or maybe those big
Bobby Kennedy teeth of his are actually
dentures who knows what kind of dirt the
Scandinavians have on bado but you're
happy to hear it no matter what it is
because why wouldn't you be plus it's
kind of amusing big mistake guess what
pal you just committed treason a
death-penalty offense accepting
assistance from a hostile foreign power
like Russia is treasonous behavior what
Donald Trump said is unamerican
unpatriotic and unbelievable he's so
wacko you'd think you know last week it
was go to the Mars and forget the moon
a month ago is go to the moon he ought
to go to the moon Roth Kramden ought to
send him but not Audrey meadows I think
the president's answer to George
Stephanopoulos yesterday underscores the
importance of moving forward with
impatient impeachment everybody in the
country should be totally appalled by
what the president said last night
totally appalled you know you've reached
a moment of maximum ridiculousness when
the people who reflexively sidewith I
don't know the government of Guatemala
over our own citizens decided to tell
you what's patriotic or not that's on
Americans says Ted Lou hilarious but if
you think that reaction was hysterical
wait till you see how the talking head
community responded pure pandemonium he
is a traitor to the pillars of our
democracy that's what that interview
shows what Donald Trump just did was the
founding fathers worst nightmare I've
run out of adjectives to react to
describe the reaction to this if any
other president had said anything
resembling this you know Republicans in
Congress would have understandably you
know what he said it it disintegrates at
the very core of what our democracy is
about this is the definition of
collusion I think recently I think it is
compromising I think it is dangerous I
think it is wrong it's illegal
dangerous wrong illegal in a word
treason that's what it is when you take
damaging information about a political
opponent from foreigners okay just so
we're clear on the terms wait a second
are we sure we're comfortable with this
new definition it seems like it might
have some unintended consequences some
of the very people making red faced
accusations of treason appear by their
own standard to have committed treason
themselves consider for example the
Trump dossier remember that everybody in
Washington read the Trump dossier John
McCain's staff made absolutely certain
of that our intelligence services then
used the dossier to justify extensive
spying on American citizens but here's
the thing about the dossier
it wasn't American our agencies the CIA
FBI they did not compile the dossier the
dossier came from a man called
Christopher steel a longtime employee
British intelligence in other words a
foreign operative steals information the
information that formed the basis of the
dossier didn't come from this country
it came from foreigners it came from
Russians everybody knew this at the time
Steele said so out loud here's a 2017
tweet from Hillary Clinton's press
secretary Brian Fallon quote I regret I
didn't know about Christopher Steele's
hiring by the Hillary campaign
pre-election he said if I had known I
would have volunteered to go to Europe
and try to help him end quote
Fallon went on to say that the Hillary
campaign was proud to get opposition
research from foreigners quote I
probably would have volunteered to go to
Europe myself to try and verify if it
would have helped get more of this out
there before the election end quote
now when Fallon says this found is
referring to salacious dirt from
Russians so by Ted Lewis tears he just
heard them
that's anti-american that's treason
and yet the funny thing is Brian Fallon
is not behind bars tonight he's never
been charged with treason or anything
else nobody on Hillary Clinton's
campaign has they're all still walking
free
despite being and we're quoting MSNBC
here traitors to the pillars of our
democracy
whatever the hell that means by this
point some of them probably moved on
maybe to lobbying for foreign
governments that's common it's a
well-worn path from political
consultants hoping to cash in it's also
by definition of betrayal of America and
yet it's so common in Washington that
nobody really notices anymore which
tells you a lot